Hey guys, it’s Jan here.
I cannot wait for Season 5 of Game Of Thrones
to kick off.
So, while we’re all gearing up to the new
season, I’m going to be taking a look at
some of the show’s highlights so far.
This video is all about Tywin Lannister’s
top 10 moments.
A no-nonsense man with an authoritative demeanour,
Tywin’s insistence on family and legacy
above all else made him the Godfather of the
Game of Thrones world.
His cruel and calculating nature was even
immortalised in song.
Remember The Rains of Castamere, which commemorated
the time Tywin brutally killed all of House
Reyne when they rebelled against his father
Tytos?
He truly was the Tywin-ator!
And Charles Dance played him to perfection,
turning the ruthless and politically savvy
Tywin into one of our favourite characters
on the show.
So, let’s countdown Tywin’s top 10 moments!
As the judges took a break from Tyrion’s
trial, Jaime offered his father a deal: in
exchange for his brother’s life, he’d
do what he’d previously refused to do.
He’d leave the Kingsguard, go to Casterly
Rock, marry a suitable woman and carry on
the Lannister line.
Tywin agreed without so much as batting an
eye, leaving Jaime looking more than a little
shocked.
Oh, Jaime, you walked right into that one,
mate!
Doh!
Good job for Jaime that Tywin’s not around
anymore to make him keep his word!
Tyrion visited his father to ask for Casterly
Rock, which he believed he was entitled to
as lawful heir, given that Kingsguard Jaime
couldn’t inherit.
Tywin, however, saw things rather differently
and told Tyrion he’d rather be consumed
by maggots than make him heir to the family
stronghold as he regarded Tyrion as an “ill-made,
spiteful little creature full of envy, lust,
and low cunning.”
In this scene, we really saw Tywin’s cruelty
and coldness to his son Tyrion, who he not
only blamed for the death of his wife Joanna
but also accused of sullying the Lannister
name by consorting with prostitutes.
He even threatened to hang the next one he
found in Tyrion’s bed.
Which is hypocritical given that Tyrion later
found his former lover Shae in Tywin’s bed.
We always knew that Tywin was a master of
the game, but apparently he was also a frustrated
school teacher.
I mean, did you see him teaching Tommen about
kingly qualities as they stood right next
to Joffrey’s corpse?
Tywin was loving it; Cersei, however, was
most definitely not.
Then there was Tywin’s classic line to Tommen,
“Your brother was not a wise king; your
brother was not a good king; if he had been,
perhaps he’d still be alive.”
He even started giving Tommen a lesson about
the birds and the bees!
Can you just imagine being taught that by
Tywin Lannister?!
Olenna may be a master of political power
games, just like Tywin, but when the Tyrell
matriarch and the Lannister patriarch went
toe to toe in season 3, it was Tywin who came
out on top, at least at the time.
It was just fantastic to watch their pretty
evenly-matched verbal sparring session as
Olenna refused to marry her grandson Loras
to Tywin’s daughter Cersei.
Little did she know that Tywin was well aware
of her plans to marry Loras to Sansa Stark!
The pair traded jibes, yet nothing would change
Olenna’s mind until Tywin played his trump
card, pulling out his quill and threatening
to make Loras part of the Kingsguard, which
would have meant no heirs or Highgarden for
him.
As Olenna caved, what a wonderful line she
delivered to Tywin: “it’s a rare enough
thing, a man who lives up to his reputation”.
In a brilliant bit of deviation from the books,
Tywin rode into Harrenhal like a boss, stopped
the prisoners being tortured by his men, and
chose Arya as his cupbearer.
Though Arya was disguised as a boy, Tywin,
immediately recognised her as a smart young
girl.
Their scenes together were great to watch
as they showed a slightly warmer side to Tywin
than usual, as he grew to sort of respect
Arya.
The best moment came when talk turned to Aegon
Targaryen who Tywin said attacked Harrenhal
with his dragons; but Arya corrected him,
adding that Aegon’s sisters Rhaenys and
Visenya were also responsible for the Targaryen
triumph.
This was the moment we saw Tywin let Arya
know that he knew she wasn’t really who
she claimed to be.
In the end, Tywin seemed to let her off the
hook, but it was certainly a dangerous moment.
To see what Charles Dance and Maisie Williams
said about shooting these scenes, check out
my interviews with them here.
The Lannisters were so famed for their wealth
that people joked Tywin Lannister even shitted
gold.
So, it was fitting he should end his days
sat on a toilet while Tyrion confronted him
with a crossbow.
And I couldn’t help but think how doubly
appropriate it was that Tywin got that crossbow
in his gut given how we first met him gutting
a stag.
The gutter became the guttee, so to speak.
Adding to the aptness of Papa Lannister’s
last scene was the fact it aired on Father’s
Day.
Yes, the parting gift Tyrion gave his father
before fleeing King’s Landing certainly
seemed well deserved.
After all, Tyrion had just discovered his
former lover Shae in Tywin’s bed and Tywin
did dismiss her as nothing more than a whore
after Tyrion revealed his love for her.
Oh yes, and there was that small matter of
Tywin having always wanted Tyrion dead.
In the end, though, it was Tyrion who was
the death of Tywin.
And as Papa Lannister shuffled off this mortal
coil, I remembered his words in season 3 to
Olenna Tyrell that his “stomach remained
quite strong”… yeah, just not quite strong
enough to withstand a crossbow, hey, Tywin?!
When Joffrey summoned Tywin to the Throne
Room to get a report on the Small Council,
let’s just say it didn’t exactly go the
way the King was hoping.
Instead of filling Joffrey in on the details,
Tywin told his grandson he was welcome to
attend the meetings himself!
I love the way Tywin still managed to talk
down to Joffrey even though he was standing
at the bottom of the steps to the Iron Throne,
and Joffrey was above him, sitting on the
Throne.
But the scene got even better when Joffrey
complained about Tywin moving the council
meetings to the Tower of the Hand, which meant
the boy-King would have to actually walk up
some steps!
Clearly, Joffrey had forgotten just who he
was dealing with at this point – I mean,
Tywin was one of the few people who wouldn’t
put up with the King’s crap, after all.
And just when you thought Tywin was intimidating
enough standing below Joffrey, he strode up
those steps to the throne and towered over
him, adding, “We could arrange to have you
carried there.”
And what about that smirk on Tywin’s face
as he walked away from the King?!
The very first time we saw Tywin on screen,
he acted like a total boss, as you’d expect,
While he gutted and skinned a stag with ruthless
efficiency, he lectured his son Jaime on the
importance of family legacy and what it really
took to be a Lannister.
And what about those great Lannister lines
that Charles Dance delivered, including “A
lion doesn’t concern himself with the opinions
of the sheep”, as he told Jaime not to worry
about what other people thought of him.
And when he gave Jaime half the Lannister
forces, he ominously told his son to remind
Catelyn Stark that “Lannisters pay their
debts”.
This was an incredible scene where we really
learned why Tywin would do anything to ensure
the Lannisters’ survival.
Oh, and of course, that stag he butchered
was a nice metaphor for the fate of House
Baratheon.
Tywin’s late arrival with an army of Lannister
and Tyrell soldiers at the Battle of Blackwater
may have saved the day.
But, could anyone other than Tywin Lannister
actually get away with riding his horse into
the King’s Throne Room without so much as
a please or thank-you?
Hell, he even let his horse shit on the threshold
to the room!
Still, knowing Tywin, I guess Joffrey and
Cersei would have just been grateful that
he didn’t leave a steaming pile of manure
right in front of the Iron Throne!
And did he get down off his steed when accepting
the titles “Saviour of the City” and “Hand
of the King” from his grandson Joffrey?
Are you out of your mind?!
This is Tywin Lannister we’re talking about!
Tywin didn’t shy away from putting anyone
in their place, so, when Joffrey started an
argument with Tyrion at a small council meeting,
threatening his uncle and vowing to serve
Robb Stark’s head to Sansa, Tywin put his
foot firmly down.
As an enraged Joffrey screamed “I am the
king”, Tywin interjected: “Any man who
must say ‘I am the king’ is no true king.
I’ll make sure you understand that when
I’ve won your war for you.”
Then, with his trademark glare, Tywin stared
down Joffrey as the boy-King accused his grandfather
of hiding under Casterly Rock while Joffrey’s
father won the real war!
Oh, Joffrey, you really overstepped the mark
there!
And by the look on your face, you realised
it, just a little bit too late!
And who can forget Tywin’s fabulous, ice-cold
reply: “The king is tired, see him to his
chambers”; which he finished off with a
final verbal slap-down, ordering Pycelle to
give Joffrey some essence of Nightshade to
help him sleep.
What a fantastic scene and who didn’t cheer
as Tywin treated Joffrey like the spoiled,
little brat he really was?!
In fact, there were so many great Tywin moments
over the seasons that I’ve got to give an
honourable mention to one moment that didn’t
quite make my top 10:
When Tyrion went to tell his father he’d
succeeded in getting the Tyrells to cough
up some cash for the royal wedding, he wasn’t
expecting to leave the meeting with an order
to marry Sansa Stark.
But that’s exactly what happened, as Tywin
told him he wasn’t about to let the Tyrells
steal the key to the north by marrying Loras
to the eldest Stark daughter.
As Cersei sat there, all smug at having stitched
up her younger brother – remember it was
her who told Tywin about the Tyrell plot – little
did she know that she was next in the line
of marital fire.
And her protests did no good as Tywin stated
stonily that she had to marry Loras, breed
and end the rumours about her once and for
all.
So what are your favourite Tywin moments?
How much are you going to miss him in the
show?
Let me know in the comments below.
Don’t forget to subscribe so you don’t
miss out on more top 10s coming up, as well
as season 5 episode reviews and exclusive
cast interviews.
Oh, and why not check out our Season 5 interviews
here with Maisie Williams, Jerome Flynn, and
Anton Lesser aka Arya, Bronn, and Qyburn.
And remember, if you’re not watching Jan
G on GoT, you know nothing!